what's up everybody we got 1 million
subscribers we don't have a thing you
know it's all those things usually
people plant stuff but it's like our
videos already take a lot of time so
it's amazing it's 1 million subscribers
later he's still a dinosaur you don't
like covered the Frog and really just in
all seriousness over the 10 years we've
been doing this you know we've kind of
jumped from channel to channel and
player 2 player and stuff and not a lot
of people online you know last even when
they do it that dedicated audience but
you followed us from place to place and
all the ups and downs and crazy moments
and stuff and we try Yakima's you try
cuz you love us and yeah and we try very
hard god go away what's the Candia to
know yeah I'm done again stop so so yeah
just guy we really are so thankful just
you know everyone's subscribing to us
and watching us after all these years I
mean we really do have the best fans and
just so thankful I gave and say thankful
too many times by which I just am so
thankful and believe us
is this the face of someone who would
lie to you
yeah would a lie and I tried to do
Spaceballs I turn Australian yeah so
just anything else everybody's got here
for this incredibly well planned video
I'm grateful like I mean I watch the
show a little bit before I even got on
and I forget it not even it just I wants
to show a little bit it's good
[Laughter]
here and there oh really like you guys
are awesome like you you've been there
since what 2007 2012 and then you guys
just kept on coming for more and it's
been awesome
like I'm really glad to see how much
progress is you know happens with still
a diverse er this is true and I'm so
pleased because by subscribing they have
enough money to put me in that old folks
home this on 60 minute you what not
twice you know what's here what you look
at us I'm playing with that candy so I'm
give you another opportunity here's the
candy do the amazing thing you were
gonna do so yeah look like I said I mean
we didn't know what this was gonna have
[Laughter]
like I said we don't know exactly what
it was gonna happen but we're so
thankful to you guys and we're gonna
keep making videos that's again one of
the reasons this one wasn't specially
prepared cuz we're in the middle of
making so uh guys just keep watching
we'll keep putting out just the great
stuff man just again just all the love
to you guys thank you so so very much
for you know your dedication you laughs
and all that great stuff so thank you
god that's a lot to clean up wait don't
go yet we have prices to hand out to all
throughout the month of December to show
our things we're gonna be handing out
blu-rays 4k blu-rays gift cards video
games and an Xbox one s as well as a ps4
we'll also be doing a charity drive in
December we'll will be raffling off a
switch and a new 3ds XL just keep
watching to see how you can win one and
thanks once again for all your support
you